The funeral arrangements will be
I will send them out in sha Allah as
soon as they're made. So,
pay attention to the WhatsApp group
in sha Allah. I'll make sure to
keep you abreast to those arrangements
in sha Allah once they
are finalized.
[Silence]
Continuing in the book of salah in
al-wajiz
So, we are continuing in the chapters
regarding the timings of prayer
from the book of prayer from al-wajiz.
Yesterday, we
read
as the author took us through a lengthy
narration
[Arabic recitation]
regarding the various timings of prayer.
That Jibreel alayhis salaam came to him
on the first day and commanded him to
pray at the starting time of each salah.
And then he came to him the following
day and told him to start praying near
the end
of the time for each salah. And then he
said to him between each of those two
these two times is the time to make
salah.
Couple of things that are important for
us to understand before we continue.
Number one, this narration of Jaber
the scholars differ
on whether or not this narration is
discussing
the bare minimum time
or the best times to pray.
And what do I mean by that?
Well, we see that for instance
Jibril alayhis salaam comes to the
prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
at
the start time of Dhuhr.
And then he comes to him at the end time
of Dhuhr.
But for Asr, he comes to him at the
start time
and then near the end time. And it's not
all the way at when the sun sets. Same
thing with Isha. He comes to him at the
start time of Isha, and he doesn't come
to him the next day at the end of Isha
per se.
He comes to him at the at the middle of
the night or at the end of the first
third of the night, etc.
So the scholars differ on whether this
narration is discussing bare minimum
meaning anything outside of these times
is considered an invalid prayer
or
this narration is speaking about the
beginning
time, which is the best time to make
salah, and the acceptable time to make
salah, but not necessarily the valid
time to make salah.
Does that make sense?
So,
is the time for Isha, for instance,
based on the understanding of this
narration, is the time for Isha,
it starts when the redness in the
western hemisphere is gone.
But, is its end time
the the at the middle of the night,
or is its end time at the break of Fajr?
This is a difference of opinion amongst
the scholars. Some say
the middle of the night is the end time
for Isha.
Meaning, if you pray Isha after the
middle of the night, the prayer is not
valid,
or you have to have a valid excuse and
necessity to do this.
Whilst others mention that no,
the
the nature of prayers
is that
every salah
is in until the next salah comes in.
It is the time for each prayer until the
next salah comes in, except for Fajr.
All of the scholars agree that Fajr ends
with the rising of the sun. And we'll
discuss this, in sha Allah. But, the
least we can learn from the narration of
Jabir is that these are the appropriate
times to make salah.
So, the appropriate time to make salah,
when is the starting time of each
prayer? Here in the narration of Jabir,
Zuhr is as soon as the sun crosses the
zenith,
and so afternoon,
right?
Number two,
Asr is when everything's
shadow
is its same length along with a little
bit that it was for Zuhr.
Maghrib is as soon as the sun, the disc
of the sun sets.
Isha is as soon as the redness in the
western sunset in the western horizon is
completely gone.
And Fajr is as soon as the dawn breaks,
the true dawn.
Then we have in the narration of Jabir,
the next day, Zuhr
was
the end time that Jibreel commanded him
was when everything's
shadow was its same length,
meaning without that small addition of
Asr.
Maghrib was the same.
Asr was when everything, the second
day he came to him, when everything's
shadow was twice its length.
Maghrib was the same. Isha
was
the
first, the end of the first half of the
night.
And in some wordings,
the end of the first third of the night.
And Fajr just before the actual sun
rise and was very bright in the
eastern horizon. Now we'll listen to
Al-Imam Al-Bukhari,
his commentary on this narration of
Jabir.
Qala At-Tirmidhiu,
At-Tirmidhi Abu Isa, he is one of the
most prominent students of al-Bukhari.
Muslim, Abu Dawud, at-Tirmidhi, they are
all students of al-Bukhari.
At-Tirmidhi
his book is
almost a companion book to Sahih
al-Bukhari because he documents the
opinions of al-Bukhari rahimahullah not
just in Hadith but also in fiqh.
At-Tirmidhi
narrates in his Jami' that
al-Bukhari al-Imam al-Bukhari said
[Silence]
So he says that al-Bukhari said, "The
most authentic narration regarding
the timings of prayers of the various
prayers is the narration of Jabir."
So it's the most authentic and what does
he mean by that? He means by a single
narration mentioning all of the five
prayers
timings.
He says Dhuhr is from
as from once the sun crosses its zenith
until everything is its own length
shadow-wise.
He says al-Asr waqtuhu min sayrurati
dhilli mithlahu ila ghurubi shams.
He says Asr, "Its time is from when
everything is its own length shadow-wise
until the sun sets."
Notice the words of al-Bukhari very
specific here.
He says, "Until the sun
sets."
He says, "Al-Maghrib
[Silence]
He says, "And the time for Maghrib is
once
the sun sets up until the red the
redness in the western horizon
completely dissipates and is gone is no
longer visible
due to the other narration of the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam in
Sahih Muslim, the time for Maghrib is as
long as there is still redness in the
western horizon."
[Silence]
He says,
"And the time for Isha is from when the
redness in the western horizon has
dissipated up until the
first half of the night has completely
passed due to the other narration of the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam also
in Sahih Muslim, the time for Salat
al-Isha is up until the first the end of
the first half of the night."
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
when the sun when the dawn first breaks
until the sun itself is visible until
the disc of the sun rises." Due to the
other narration of the Prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam also in Sahih
Muslim,
he says, "The time of the morning prayer
Fajr is from when
the
dawn first breaks until the sun has
risen until the the sun is visible."
Now,
having said that, we will hear some
other narrations regarding Isha. We will
hear some other narrations regarding
Asr. We'll discuss those details in sha
Allah when we arrive at that.